bonsoir le 7-8 nouvelle édition réalisée
en direct à 18h en ce 25 octobre nous
allons notamment parlé de la fête de
l'aïd el kébir avec une autre invitée
mohamedou vannes bonsoir il vous êtes le
porte parole de l'association des
musulmans de saint cyr l'école et de
fontenay le fleury
demain ce sera la grande fête de l'islam
de 20 vendredi mais j'aimerais avant
tout votre réaction à ce chiffre c'est
le chiffre de cette édition du 7 8 60 60
% des français qui estiment que
l'influencé la visibilité de l'islam
sont aujourd'hui trop importante en
france c'est 5 % de plus qu'il ya
seulement deux ans et je continue
toujours avec ce même sondage ils sont
même 43 % à considérer que la présence
d'une communauté musulmane est plutôt
une menace pour l'identité du pays
l'identité de la france quelle est votre
réaction c'est très intéressant je
n'avais pas pris connaissance de ces
chiffres là avant de venir nous voir
mais c'est très intéressant et je pense
que l'on peut sans se tromper dire qu'il
ya deux choses à tirer de ces deux
chiffres que vous voulez donner le
premier chiffre concernant les 60% de
français qui estiment aujourd'hui que la
visibilité au niveau de la communauté
musulmane est trop importante et qu'elle
peut être néfaste pour l'épauler pour
les valeurs de la république
je pense que c'est justement un des
objectifs d'une association comme la
nôtre c'est de justement veiller à ce
que la compréhension et qui n'est pas d'
amalgame entre les différentes thèses
comme honda ou différentes positions
différentes connaissances au
méconnaissance de l'islam qu'on peut
avoir
donc c'est tout à fait légitime mais je
pense que ça prouve que c'est nécessaire
d'aller l'un vers l'autre les hommes
vers les autres pour discuter pour
s'expliquer pour débattre des idées
savoir exactement quelle est la place de
l'islam en france
est-ce que c'est l'islam tel qu'il est
conçu par certains extrémistes ou c'est
l'islam tel qu'il est connu en france et
qu'il a toujours eue à vivre en france
parce que tous les immigrés qui ont eu à
manifester leur vouloir de vivre un
islam en france même si je ne parlerai
pas de l'islam de france
mais l'islam étant ce qu'il est parce
que faire la distinction entre l'islam
de france et l'islam d'ailleurs c'est
dire que donc il y a plusieurs islam il
n'y a qu'un seul islam le vrai ceux qui
sont dans la négation des valeurs
républicaines ce sont ceux qui ne savent
pas exactement en quoi consistent les
vraies valeurs de l'islam
ceux qui sont 60% à dire qu'aujourd'hui
la visibilité est trop importante
c'est peut-être parce que depuis un
certain nombre d'années la communauté
musulmane de france s'est rendu compte
qu'elle était sous représentée entre
guillemets sous représentés je ne parle
pas de façon de du thème politique je
parle pas de représentativité nationale
au niveau des assemblées autres même si
cette question pourrait se poser mais
surtout aussi au niveau de la pratique
de leur culte
ils ont estimé que s'il ne prenait pas
les choses en main la personne ne
viendrait les trouver pour dire que ça
soit un maire que ce soit un préfet que
ce soit un ministre personne ne les
trouverez pour dire venez je vais vous
construire une mosquée je vais vous
construire un lieu de culte et comme on
a tendance aujourd'hui à toujours
rapproché cette apparition soudaine 7
cette visibilité soudaine de l'islam en
france par rapport à différents
événements que pour nos vies en france
comme à l'étranger
on s'est dit finalement est-ce que c'est
une bonne chose pour nous autres qui ne
sont pas musulmans et qui pensent ont
représenté les vraies valeurs de la
république parce que c'est votre travail
le travail de votre association
notamment sa chance au niveau avait reçu
déjà l'an passé sur ce plateau pour
parler des initiatives que vous menez
des rapprochements avec les différentes
les religieuses absolue notamment vous
restez avec nous sur ce plateau on va
vous retrouver dans quelques instants le
temps d'accueillir alesi gastines
bonsoir à licence arrive comme tous les
jeudis la page de l'écho dans un peu
moins d'une demi-heure
oui cette chronique va être consacré à
l'actualité un petit peu mouvementée
pour les chefs d'entreprise nous verrons
quelles peuvent être leurs inquiétudes
avec le medef des yvelines
alice vous restez sur ce plateau la page
écho dans un peu moins d'une demi heure
mais également ce soir nous allons
parler avec vous de cette problématique
qui concerne la fête de l'aïd cette
année il n'y aura pas d' abattoir mobile
et vous pourrez réagir et nous expliquer
pourquoi c'est un problème pour la
communauté musulmane à noter que je
recevrai également ce soir les hauteurs
de mémoire en images la ville de plaisir
se raconte à travers les cartes postales
et de son côté charlotte le long nous
présentera son exposition à la
commanderie des templiers
c'est du côté des longs cours voilà un
aperçu de son travail les salariés
d'alcatel toujours mobilisés à vélizy
il ya tout juste une semaine la
direction d'alcatel lucent annoncé la
fermeture du site de vélizy d'ici à 2013
le groupe prévoit la suppression de plus
de 5000 emplois dans le monde dont près
de 1500 postes en france ce matin 350
salariés d'alcatel à vélizy ont rejoint
200 collègues au centre de nozay dans
l'essonne pour une assemblée générale
c'est sur ce site que des employés iv
noah devrait être transféré après la
fermeture des locaux de vélizy on va
entendre à ce sujet didier ringot
délégué cgt sur le site de vélizy pour
alcatel lucent on écoute directe
là bas des gens
on est allé
visitez la cantine puisqu'on nous dit
que c'est là-bas qu'on va devoir
s'installer si le site de vélizy ferme
donc déjà on voit qu'aujourd'hui
ban au site il est pas prêt à nous
accueillir n'ya pas les bâtiments il
n'ya pas les infrastructures
donc on sait que si jamais on doit aller
là bas ça va être la galère pendant des
années en attendant que le site soit
soit prêt à nous accueillir
et puis on a fait une assemblée générale
des salariés pour pour expliquer qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on se mobilise et qu'on
se mobilise vite et fort parce que la
direction elle va frapper vite et fort
aussi est officiellement aucune date de
nouvelle mobilisation de manifestations
n'a encore filtré des différentes
assemblées générales qui se sont tenues